Why the Irish hate the British, simple enough for a kid to understand.
It didn't start with one thing. It built over 800 years.
Britain invaded Ireland in the 12th century, took the land, gave it to English settlers.
Irish people became tenants on land their families had farmed for generations.
Then came the penal laws. Irish Catholics couldn't vote, couldn't own land, couldn't hold public
office, couldn't practice their religion openly, couldn't speak their own language in court.
Being Irish was made illegal in your own country. Then the famine hit,
1845. One million dead, another million fled.
Britain controlled Ireland's food supply and kept exporting grain while people starved in the
streets. Irish children watched food leave their country on ships while their families died.
In 1916 the Irish rebelled. Britain executed the leaders publicly, one by one.
It turned moderates into revolutionaries overnight. Ireland finally won independence in 1922,
but Britain kept the north. That partition split families, communities, and cities.
It led to decades of bombings and assassinations that didn't end until 1998. 800 years of
invasion, starvation, and partition. That's why. And that's just one story inside Paladin.
It's like Duolingo, but for history lovers. Addictive, smart, surprisingly fun.
Try it now and become the most intelligent person in the room.